[Music]
welcome to rhyming city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah that really
worked out
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me I've been
so lonely they try to talk to me all the
time all they hear is pika pika you can
hear him right guys adorable you're
adorable they can't understand me kiss
you no one else here
I don't need a Pokemon period and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic is
called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving he's
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you